can we not say anything about the
difficulties in establishing life in the
cosmos at large so first of all it's
extremely difficult to extrapolate from
an example a single case we all know
that human mathematicians generally need
to to do an infinite regression what we
can say it seems to me and I try and say
in the book is that because we know that
Mars and Earth exchange material and
because Mars appeared too early on have
been more amenable with the conditions
to the life like we know it that it's
not impossible that when you want to
look see what a martian looks like look
in the mirror that like first the rose
of Mars but we also know that Mars as a
planet has certain features that ours
doesn't and evolved in a way that made
it inhospitable and so what will be very
important is actual data